Speaker 1: So the Kanye West to anti-Semitism,
anti-Jewish comments just will not stop. We have
another short interview to look at. And again, I
want to really explain to you all the reason I'm
content. I don't care about Kanye West. I don't
I don't care about him as an artist and I don't
care about him as part of the cultural milieu.
What concerns me about Kanye West is that it is
the prototypical example of a guy who is saying
insane things about Jews, and it's just not taken
as seriously in social media and elsewhere as
it would be if it was some other individual,
a white person, for example, attacking a different
group. And this is the soft indifference to
anti-Semitism that I have spoken about before.
West is unhinged. Let's look at some clips. He
was interviewed by Chris Cuomo now on News Nation,
which is that it's a new channel of some kind.
Asked about the anti-Semitic comments
themselves and here's what he had to say.
Speaker 2: Couldn't it also be that you have said
things that offend the community guidelines like
anti-Semitic comments and things that are seen
as insensitive and potentially threatening to
communities that we try to protect?
Speaker 4:
Well, I don't like the term anti-Semitic.
Speaker 1: Yeah, a lot of anti-Semites don't.
Speaker 4: It's been a term that's allowed
people specifically in my industry to get away
to get away with murder, sometimes literally.
Speaker 1: While literal murder is happening
because of the word anti-Semitism.
Speaker 4: You know, and get away with
robbing and doing bad people.
Speaker 1: People a lot of
robbing happens because of the word
anti-Semitism. This is this is sick.
Speaker 4: Boy, say I got screwed on a deal.
Is it? Would that be come as a surprise to you
if I said, hey, a music exec screwed someone
on a deal? Does that sound kind of like normal
commonplace to you? So for me.
Speaker 2: It doesn't have
anything to do with being anti-Semitic.
Speaker 1: And it does if you're Kanye, because
his argument is that the Jews are screwing him.
Speaker 2: As you believe that all record
producers are Jewish or, you know, it's when
you talk about Jewish people specifically is
targeting them for anti-Semitic.
Speaker 4: But I don't believe
in that term. One thing is.
Speaker 1: He doesn't believe in it,
guys. Imagine if someone said after you, after
throwing around the N-word and they were like,
that's that's insanely racist. And they
go, I don't believe in the term racist. Oh,
all right. Well, I guess it's fine.
Speaker 4: Black people are also,
too, I classify as Jew also. And so I actually
can't be anti-Semitic. So the term, yeah.
Speaker 1: Kanye can't be anti-Semitic because
he also is Jew, as he likes to say. I'm not
going to do the full explanation now about this
entire black Israelite 12 lost Tribes thing.
I've already done it a bunch of times before,
but that movement in and of itself is quite a
racist movement. Here's another segment from
this just completely delusional interview in which
Kanye says he's been texting with Kid Rock, which
doesn't come as a huge surprise to be able to say.
Speaker 4: It's actually something Kid Rock just
gave me a text about that. Go to places where
you're celebrating that, where you're just
tolerated. Oh, you know, I bring up LA.
Speaker 1: He's his. Kanye is upset that
his anti he has very in a very he
wants to be given some kind of prize
for calling out the Jews. Essentially, he's
not being celebrated for his anti-Semitism.
Speaker 4: I bring a lot of attention
to these platforms, to Instagram and
to Twitter. And they silo you. They they
shadow banned you. Every one of those that
was shadow favorite scrapped. Yeah, exactly.
Speaker 1: And what's wild is he's even using
the rhetoric of these right wingers. The right
wingers always tell me, David, you've shadow
banned me on your platform, and they get it from
prominent right wingers and Republicans who have
been talking about shadow bans for a while. And
now Kanye is using it. This guy's disgusting.
It's not getting the reaction that I believe
it deserves. And now potentially Kanye is going
to by himself, social media platform. Parler,
which we talked about on yesterday's bonus show